>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D. C.
>> Gail Shirazi: Okay, hello.
We're ready to start
our program today.
I'm Gail Shirazi of the Israel and
Judaica section here at the library.
The program today is Global
Refugees: The Case of Jews
and Greeks in 20th
Century Czechoslovakia.
The program is cosponsored
by the European division here
at the library, the Hebrew
language table, and in cooperation
with the Embassy of
the Czech Republic.
This program was another
collaborative program,
thanks to Michelin Amir
the Holocaust Museum
who is always sharing
wonderful ideas
with us to bring to the library.
I want to thank -- yay, Michelin.
[ Applause ]
I want to thank the
European division,
Graham Harris and Erica Spencer.
Our geography and map division for
helping scholars with their maps.
The Czech embassy, Robert
Rajak, and Mary Fetzko.
Audrey Fisher of the press
office and Galina Cheverovsky
and Kayam Bozak [spelling assumed]
of the Israel Judaic section.
And thanks to our speakers today,
Amy Kaslow, Dr. Michal Frankl
and Dr. Katerina Kralova.
Amy Kaslow is a columnist,
photo journalist and activist
on behalf of world refugees.
For over 30 years she has written
about lives disrupted by war.
These stories are reflected in her
photographic exhibit called Victims,
Perpetrators, Eyewitnesses
and Survivors: Life after War.
She is a White House appointee
to the governing board
of the US Holocaust Museum.
Both Dr. Frankl and Dr.
Kralova are fellows at the Jack,
Joseph and Morton Mandel Center
for Advanced Holocaust Studies
at the US Holocaust Museum.
And I'll give brief biographies
because we have a lot to do today.
Dr. Frankl is head of the Jewish
studies and history of anit-Semitism
at the Prague Jewish Museum.
He has written extensively on
German and Austrian refugees
in Czechoslovakia prior
to World War II.
Dr. Kralova is assistant
professor of contemporary history
at the faculty of social science
the Charles University in Prague.
She is fluent in Greek,
Czech, English and German.
I have two announcements
to make before we start.
Please turn off your cell phones.
And this is being webcast.
And when it comes to the
question and answer period,
it's going to span the audience.
So if you don't want to be taped,
you can leave at that point.
Thank you.
I'd like to introduce Amy Kaslow.
[ Applause ]
>> Amy Kaslow: So good afternoon.
It's a nice turnout.
I'm going to talk very briefly
about Victims, Perpetrators,
Eyewitnesses and Survivors.
They are longtime refugees
languishing in camps.
They're soldiers whom
unemployed meeting
for a smoke or idle conversation.
They're elderly savoring a
bowl of soup in a soup kitchen.
They're children whose
playground is a toxic dump.
Unfortunately, past is prologue.
And with today's parallels,
we see a lot of challenges.
And I think a lot of this
landscape will be familiar to you.
We're talking about
a lost generation.
We're talking about trauma,
corruption, security issues.
Justice, elusive justice.
This is 1989 Baghdad.
This little fellow is along
the banks of the Tigris River.
He's a beggar who's hustling a
foreign visitor with card tricks
and he was a rare sight at the time.
But since the Gulf War, intra-Iraqi
fighting, countless insurgencies
and of course the ISIS assault on
Iraq's independence, such as it was,
the number of young
Iraqi beggars has soared.
Traditionally pampered,
even insulated
by protective Arab parents --
and you find this all
over the Arab world.
Children here and throughout
these conflict areas are peddling
everything from cigarettes to sex.
And it is an absolute 180-degree
difference in the prospect
for children growing up in
conflict areas in the Middle East.
These folks back from the
front, eight-year war with Iran,
these Iraqi men, are shopping for
wedding dresses for their intended.
By now they've married.
They've probably had
multiple children.
And those children now,
if past is prologue,
those children now are suffering
from the same kinds of difficulties
that the beggar boy,
30 years earlier,
20 years earlier, suffered from.
Unaccompanied children are the
most tragic byproducts of conflict.
And the most vulnerable, of course.
These three are orphans who escaped
Vukovar, which is a Croatian town,
emblematic of the massacres,
the mass graves
and the widespread devastation
of post-war Yugoslavia.
Raped, tortured, often
forced to watch
as their own family members
endured this, victims were refugees
and their lives only
became more complicated.
They languished in those UN camps
and other hastily constructed homes.
And as we see today,
government agencies,
international relief organizations
try to provide the basics.
Food, health, housing.
But those efforts fall
severely short of needs.
In this instance, in Croatia,
the state radio devoted hours
to desperate family
members who were calling
out for their family
members on the air.
And it was and remains crushing.
This is a very familiar site.
It is a refugee camp.
This one in Macedonia right
near the Albanian border.
This is just post-Kosovo,
part of Yugoslavia.
These families lived in
horrendous conditions.
This particular camp was built
on top of a toxic waste site
and had plastic sheeting put on top
of it and then soil on top of that.
The toxicity leaked of course and
there were a lot of open sores
and a lot of health issues among
the refugees living in these camps.
So even the camps themselves
can create big, big problems.
Forget about busting
out of the camps.
This is a sheep herder, a
Palestinian sheep herder, 1983,
ten years after the '73 war.
He entered a world back then
that was profoundly impacted
by the divide between Israel
and its Arab neighbors.
Today, the majority of west
bank Arabs are youth, his age.
And upward of 50% of the
population is under the age of 15.
There is staggering unemployment
in this cohort, perhaps 30,
maybe as high as 60% unemployment.
The data swings wildly on this.
But it is among the
highest in the world.
These toy assault rifles
were dangling
from an east Jerusalem
shop fairly recently.
And they are marketed to five- and
six-year-old Palestinian girls.
If past is prologue, and I
think this is a recurring theme
in our daily lives, trying to
grapple with these just collections
of strife all over the world.
This is the kind of sort
of subliminal training
that comes out of conflict.
This is the end of the
Cold War, or is it?
Some say no.
But the end of the Cold War
and the fall of communism,
at least the first fall, was a major
shredding of the command economy.
And any kind of safety
net that caught folks
who needed housing,
healthcare and food.
Hardship really spared no one,
except for the privileged few,
those who had protection.
And this is a Russian woman.
This is not a Russian Jew.
This is a Russian woman
who has no medical care.
She has no food.
She needs money.
She has no job and she needs
to look after her family.
The aging suffer probably the
most in post-war societies.
They're often shut out of services
or simply forgotten or ignored
by those who have undergone
trauma themselves.
This group is very smartly dressed.
They put on their Sunday best every
time they go to the soup kitchen.
It's a famous one in Moscow.
It's called Hama and some of these
patrons ride the very dangerous
metro in Russia in Moscow.
They ride two hours each way
to get a hot meal each day.
Their penchants of
course have shriveled.
Government assistance has
vanished and fuel and food prices
of course have gone
through the roof.
This for them is just the
latest in a succession
of horrors they have
suffered over many decades.
I don't have to remind many
in this group there were
pogroms, anti-Jewish pogroms.
The Holocaust, the Gulag,
Stalin's forced labor camps.
Refused immigration.
Banishment to Siberia.
Viscous anti-Semitic attacks.
The wrath of skinheads,
the ellipsis, it goes on.
Today the soup kitchen serves
hundreds of indigent Jews.
Most of these people live in
isolated, decrepit apartments
and houses, some with no
running water or heat.
This is Srebenica.
I was there last summer
with the Holocaust Museum.
We were part of the delegation
observing the 20th anniversary
of the commemoration of
the massacre in Srebenica,
which is on the border
of Bosnia and Serbia.
And it's a mountaintop place.
It's really a remarkable
place to get to.
Lots of nips and tucks
and big turns.
It's probably emblematic to most as
sustaining one of the most savage,
most horrific assaults
of the Balkan Wars.
This survivor is cradling
a child and a grandchild.
And she is among the many
Muslim women who fled and lived
in the forest on roots and leaves
and other nutrients she could find.
The women came back
after this assault
and they came back
obviously to destroyed houses.
Their men, their boys were gone.
Most of the girls were gone.
The children were gone.
Houses pockmarked by shells.
Fields were laid with mines.
Constant reminders of terror that
should have ended decades ago.
But those things are
still very present.
There are many, many swaths of
areas around Srebenica for example,
and throughout the
Balkans that are minefields
and difficult to traverse.
In Srebenica and throughout Bosnia,
Muslim women suffered enormous shame
when they were left with
babies born from sexual attack.
This is a young woman in Guatemala,
where there is full-out gang war,
as there is throughout
the northern triangle
in Honduras and El Salvador.
This particular Central American
nation ranks among the worst
and most violent countries.
And women and girls are
the most vulnerable.
They are under intense
pressure to marry.
Legal age is 14 but they bear
children before they even really
learn how to take care
of themselves.
And it's something that is so --
it's repeated so often
throughout the world.
I'm just giving you a little
snippet to think about.
Slightly older.
This is Nigeria.
Like so many nations embroiled
in or emerging from conflict,
Nigerians are just strangled.
They're strangled by corruption.
They're strangled by fear.
The country has huge debt
and crumbling infrastructure.
Even as it pumps billions
of dollars' worth of oil.
That's how corrupt it is.
More than two-thirds of the citizens
live below the poverty line.
HIV/AIDS, the top killer,
is still quite vicious.
And its staggering infection
rate is the third highest
in the world behind
India and South Africa.
These villagers have
no running water,
no electricity, no telephones.
And they have the only health
clinic in the area for 37 villages.
That health clinic
has a plastic curtain
with two rooms that are barren.
No drugs, no facility.
The most naked feeling of course
for the women and the girls is
that they're vulnerable to
the radical Islamic groups,
especially Boko Haram who is
widely known for kidnapping
and sexually enslaving girls, as
those cradled in this woman's arms.
Gangs and opportunism.
Well, this is Brazil
outside one of the favelas,
which is these squatter
settlements and impoverished areas
that line the big cities
in the country.
There is full-out gang warfare
throughout this part of the world.
And this gentleman has
been captured, happily so,
into a work program
sponsored by an NGO.
He's left the gang in
favor of a full-time job.
And he's lugging a sack
of bottles for recycling.
The gang war is just
gripping in El Salvador.
This woman lost all of her boys.
It's been over four years since
this gang truce in El Salvador.
It's a broker deal designed to
reduce the number of killings.
Not to reduce them all told.
Just to reduce the numbers, in
exchange for prison transfers.
It's really hit the skids of course.
This fellow is a young boy
whose mother commutes upwards
of five hours a day round trip
for her work as a housekeeper
for more well-to-do Salvadorans.
He does not leave his
corrugated metal housing.
Does not even go outside
because gang members live
next door, across the street.
And nothing is sacred.
This is where he lives.
This is a typical drive
through a street in El Salvador.
It's pretty tense.
And if you go to most of the places
where there are ongoing strife,
you'll find this kind of presence.
These are the backs
of genocide heirs.
These are the Rwandan perpetrators.
Some of them who wiped out nearly
800,000 Tutsis in just 100 days
with machetes, hatchets,
clubs, knives, spears.
They cleansed cities, as
they said, in the countryside
of what they called cockroaches.
There's a lot of inflammatory
speech,
which we see at the Holocaust Museum
and elsewhere as a leading indicator
of much more violent behavior.
The Hutu rallying cries were laced
with hate speech spewed by leaders
on the radio, in churches.
This is possible distinguished as
the fastest genocide in history.
Left the country with
more than 100,000 orphans
and 250,000 rape victims.
A traumatized population
for generations.
Yes, I'm getting a wrap-up, so I'm
going to give you a few more faces.
This woman was left for dead,
crawled back from one of the piles
of bodies in Rwanda inside a church
where she had gone for safe haven.
And the divets in her
forehead and around her skull,
you can see where the
hatchet marks were.
This is an example of someone
who sought refuge, a refugee.
Somebody who's now living where
she came from, returned refugee.
And somebody who has to
make it through her life.
And you can imagine the trauma.
I'm going to wrap up with these two.
These are octogenarian eyewitnesses.
These are Ukrainian
neighbors who recall 1943
when the Nazi soldiers marched
through Rava Ruska with 1,500 Jews
into the forest just a few
miles from the Polish border.
And they are recalling
this Holocaust by bullet.
He was not recalling as clearly
as she would have liked him to,
so she gave him a little
stimulation and she reminded him
that his own family provided
the horse that carried the cart
of limp bodies to the mass graves.
And she said that her mother had
to supply their kitchen table
to the Nazis to rest
guns and to consume food.
The Nazis needed a little
snack in between their murders.
Last, I will leave you with the
Buddhist nuns outside of Nanpean.
These women have shaved heads
because they symbolize widowhood.
Their husbands were murdered by
the Khmer Rouge and today they live
in a monastery built near the site
of a Khmer Rouge prison
and execution ground.
And as you probably know, an
international court outside
of Nanpean is pursuing charges
against the Khmer Rouge
founders, strategists, operatives.
It's an effort towards
representative justice.
They can't possibly
try all the millions
of people who were perpetrators.
These women, 30 years after the
genocide, these women are part
of a nation where everyone
is a survivor, where victims
and perpetrators live side-by-side.
And where the narrative
has a lot of holes in it
because there are a
lot of non-truths.
But here at this former
execution ground turned monastery,
the abiding belief is karma.
So thank you for this
brief introduction
into the beautiful conversation.
[ Applause ]
>> Michel Frankl: Good afternoon.
Many thanks to both institutions,
the Library of Congress as well
as the US Holocaust Memorial
Museum for helping us
with setting up this event.
We are very pleased that we can from
the perspective of two historians
who deal with Czech in my case
or central European, and Czech
and Greek and many other
histories in Katerina's case
that we can contribute to a debate
which is becoming more central
and more global as the title
of this session indicates.
And many thanks for
this very stimulating
and also very emotional
introduction that reminded us
that refugees suffering is something
which is still very much with us.
My presentation at least is
going to be about history.
And I am going to discuss
the parallels as well
as the differences, then we will
do question and answers later on.
But I must say that as somebody
who came here in summer,
the end of August, from central
Europe, from the Czech Republic --
as somebody who tries to make
clear to the Czech Republic
that discussion about refugees,
the history of refugee
policy is an important topic
and shouldn't be ignored.
Coming here right at the moment
when refugees were just streaming,
flowing across the region
was very difficult for me.
And it is a very strange feeling
watching the European refugee crisis
from abroad.
But it's also another
enriching perspective.
One of my motivations
for researching refugees
of Czechoslovakian refugee
policy was that if you look
at what has been written
about Jewish
and non-Jewish refugees during the
Nazi time, during the Holocaust,
there's been much focus
on western countries.
Western Europe, United
States, United Kingdom.
And much less attention to the east.
As if refugees were just a
topic of liberal democracies
and the question was
only, "How is it possible
that liberal democracies guided by
their values or not so have failed
to deal with the Holocaust?"
This is the very simplified notion
that you can see very often.
However, refugees are also going
to the east, whatever it is.
And it is also in eastern Europe or
if you want post-communist Europe
where the history of refugees,
the history of refugee
policy should be discussed
and where society should try
to come to terms with that.
Would it help in the current crisis?
I don't know.
But I believe it will
create a better environment,
more informed environment for
discussing where we are today.
Czechoslovakia, and we are now
going to focus on Czechoslovakia,
is known historically, especially
in the integral period,
as a place of refuge.
It is very often idealized.
And the goal of our two
presentations is not necessarily
to turn this upside down, but rather
to provide alternative perspectives
and more information for discussion.
Let me start with a specific event.
Shortly after midnight
on March 12th,
1938 an usually full train arrived
at a Czechoslovakian border
station of Bratislava.
And those on board were not usual
passengers of a sleep night express.
Most of them had packed only
the most necessary items.
After hearing the news
of the German troops
and Gestapo approaching towards
Vienna via the Anschluss of Austria.
For endangered anti-Nazi
activists and many Jews,
the Czechoslovak border seemed
to be the best way and one
of the last escape ways as
well to avoid the Nazi rule.
Among them was Richard Berman,
journalist and a staunch critic
of the Austrian Christian
Social and [inaudible].
And he recorded his
excitement on arrival
into the free Czechoslovakia.
I quote, "Finally I will
sail to Greece again.
I was delivered safe."
He therefore found it hard
to believe what followed
after the train pulled
into Bratislava.
All refugees were forced out of the
train and after a couple of hours
of tense waiting they
were returned to what had
in the meantime become
Nazi-ruled Austria.
In Burman's narrative, the image
of freedom, both personal and that
of the country of Czechoslovakia,
this image turned in the description
of an ugly and prison-like waiting
room at the railway station.
And this is apparently a
description of a real place.
This place can be viewed
as a symbolic expression
of the profound surprise
and disillusionment
with democratic Czechoslovakia.
Justs before being returned
to Austria, Burman managed
to telegram the Czechoslovakian
president Edvard Benes,
whom who he knew personally.
And you can see the
telegram on the slide.
Appealing for the refugees
to be accepted.
And this message ended up without
any reaction or any answer.
It ended up in the archives
of the Czechoslovakian
ministry of interior.
I picked a little bit of the
language of that very short telegram
and you can see that it
does appeal to the humanity
of the Czechoslovak democracy.
And I'd like to connect this
with this element of surprise
that Burman must have experienced.
And apparently he was
not the only observer
to perceive this contradiction
between the image
of democratic Czechoslovakia and the
same country turning back refugees.
He certainly could remember how
Czechoslovakia was deceiving
anti-Nazi refugees.
In 1934 for instance, from
Austria, after the suppression
of the leftist uprising in
Vienna and other cities,
when approximately
2,000 social democrats
and communists were
living in Czechoslovakia.
So the point I'm trying to make when
I focus on this particular event is
that what Burman couldn't understand
and what he was trying to come
to terms with was one of the
most profound, important shifts,
if not the most important shift
in the Czechoslovak refugee
policy in the 20th century.
And apparently refugee policy
is all about categorization
of people, unfortunately.
Who is a refugee?
What is this based on?
What groups should be allowed on?
And these refugees in Bratislava
in 1938 witnessed a
shift of categories.
First Burman and other perceived
themselves and others as opponents
of Nazism and the language
is connected to the language
of political opposition to Nazism.
So first they perceive
themselves as opponents of Nazism.
Czechoslovak authorities
treated them as Jews,
which meant in this particular
case, as unwanted Jewish migrants.
We do not have much time to discuss
Czechoslovak refugee policy before
this point, but apparently interval
Czechoslovakia was not all bad.
Interval Czechoslovakia
served as a refuge
to refugees from the Soviet Union.
It became a temporary home
to a lot of people escaping
from Nazi Germany, as well as to
the Austrians whom I mentioned.
Most of these people who came before
1938 wouldn't experience something
like that.
They wouldn't experience
refusal on the border.
They would have had a
program, especially the fact
that Czechoslovakia
wouldn't consider them
as permanent residents.
Czechoslovakia is at this time
thought of rather as a place
for temporary refuge before
the refugees will find a final
definitive home, for
instance somewhere overseas.
Yet if you look at a policy,
a rather liberal policy
towards anti-Nazi refugees,
starting with 1933, we can
see that all these groups
that were excluded
from this tolerance.
And in a very simplified way I could
say that these were two groups.
One was people who were
considered to be eastern Jews,
especially Jews of Polish origin.
So stateless Jews.
And the other group were communists.
I'm not going to go
into details about this,
and we can leave it to discussion.
However, we can see in the second
half of the 1930's especially
after the Nuremburg Laws, 1935 in
Germany, we can see that elements
of ethnic categorization and
elements of, if you want,
administered anti-Semitism,
are sneaking in in the practice
of Czechoslovakia refugee policy.
And it's a longer process
of categorizing all Jews,
all Jewish refugees, as what
was called the eastern Jews,
those who were unwanted, to those
who were understood to be something
in the very opposition to the
notion of proper citizenship.
Thus the border closure of 1938
doesn't come out of nothing.
Now let me come back to 1938 and
just give you a couple of episodes,
and these are only examples.
Throughout the spring
and summer of 1938,
Czechoslovak border guards
were routinely hunting refugees
around the border with Austria.
And along the swampy
banks of the Danube.
And I don't know how many
refugees were turned back.
Neither do I know how many
made it into Czechoslovakia.
But I've extrapolated
from very partial sources
that there might be some 10,000
cases of return of refugees.
Which is a large number for
those of us who can remember
for instance the discussions
about the Swiss policy
in 1938 and then again in 1942.
These are very similar numbers.
The Czechoslovakian and Swiss
numbers are rather similar.
So there's never been a significant
discussion in the Czech Republic
or Czechoslovakia about this event.
On this particular slide,
let me just make a short
remark about the map.
I picked up a map which
includes the events of 1939
so that you can see protectorate
Moravia, so occupied Czechoslovakia.
In 1938, the time we talk
about, this is not yet the case.
But that was all the borders we need
for understanding the
story that we discuss here.
I've picked an event on
the shores of the Danube.
A refugee from Vienna named Pavel
Kostner who was born actually
in Czechoslovakia in
Bratislava, escaping from Vienna.
He's caught by the Czechoslovakian
border police and they report
in very cold language
how he committed suicide.
This is an extreme case.
It's not typical.
It's an extreme case.
But it testifies to the
very extremity of the nature
of the Czechoslovakian
refugee policy.
And Czechoslovakian refugee
policy was not exceptional.
It was typical at this time.
The extremes of the refugee policy
were also illustrated on the fate
of a group of Jews from [inaudible].
Jews who were brought by the
Austrian side during the night.
One night in mid-April,
1938 across the Danube.
Czechoslovak officials found them
in the morning freezing, wet.
They fed them.
They sent them back immediately.
And then the same thing was then
repeated on the Hungarian border.
The group was subjected
to humiliating labor
on the Austrian side of the border.
And had to survive in a region where
the borders of the three states met.
Eventually, the Bratislava community
found the only solution available
and accommodated them
on a towboat anchored
on the Hungarian side of the Danube.
The Danube counted as
international borders.
That's why none of the three
states could really intervene.
And here you can see a short excerpt
from a report about the situation
on the boat and the
terrible situation.
Suffering, spiritual and physical,
to which these people
were subjected.
It took three or four
months, during which none
of the three states was willing
to provide even a temporary refuge
to arrange for the emigration,
overseas, mostly to Palestine
and to the United States of America.
Now the policy that was developed
towards Austrian Jews became model
in 1938.
And it was replicated against
other groups of refugees.
But very interestingly, and
this is yet another shift
in the Czechoslovakian
refugee policy.
The groups that followed,
that were excluded,
were Czechoslovak citizens,
former Czechoslovak citizens.
And their own country was trying
to not allow them or to expel them
or to have them emigrate
as quickly as possible.
It was almost as an automatic reflex
that Czech officials
were sending back Jewish
and also some German
refugees from Sudetenland
after the Munich Agreement.
And after the Christian Act.
After the Munich Agreement,
the border areas
of Czechoslovakia were
annexed to Nazi Germany.
And they were also dumping
Jews with Polish citizenship
across the border in Ostrava.
And I've just included a quote
from a letter by Ilsa Verber,
in which she testifies
about the horrible scenes
in the no man's land.
No man's land is a
proliferating term by this time.
Into no man's land on the
Czechoslovak/Polish border.
I could add many more events
on the Czechoslovak border
of something I call not
just a physical border,
but a border of citizenship in the
sense that refugees, and this is one
of my conclusions here
-- that the development
of the restrictive policy
towards refugees is essential
in reframing the rules of
citizenship, also for those
that are not yet refugees.
So that Jewish refugees coming from
the outside were contributing --
or rather the policy towards
such refugees was contributing
towards eroding the rights
of Jews living inside
of the country.
And one thing that is connected
with this is also a revision
of citizenship in Czechoslovakia
instituted in January 1939,
similar to for instance Polish or
Romanian revisions of citizenship.
A revision of citizenship
which stripped Jews who escaped
from Sudetenland of their
Czechoslovakian citizenship.
I have just picked one single case
of a person, random case of a person
who was denaturalized
in this process.
Therefore, the refugees were
discounted citizenship became an
impulse, or perhaps
if you want a pretext,
to revise citizenship
along ethnic lines.
So refugees and citizenship are
always interconnected categories.
And it's important that we
think about them in this way.
As a conclusion,
1938 in Czechoslovakia is
certainly a turning point.
And by this turning point,
Czechoslovakia ceased
to be a refuge, but
rather became a country
that was generating refugees.
It was a county which increasingly,
especially after the second World
War, understood itself as homogenous
in terms of nationality
or ethnicity.
I just mentioned that
Czechoslovak Germans
and some Hungarians were expelled
after the second World War.
And because we don't have much
time, this gives me the opportunity
to invite Katerina who will
show a totally different facet
of the Czechoslovakian
refugee policy.
[ Applause ]
>> Katerina Kralova:
Hello and welcome.
It's wonderful to see so
many guests around here.
And I would say that
many of you have the one
or the other experience
of being an immigrant.
Be it from the Czech
Republic, Czechoslovakia,
Greece or somewhere else,
coming to the United States.
Or maybe passing other
countries as well.
I would like to thank the Library
of Congress, which I am delighted
to use for my research and read
those books which aren't covered
by the hosting institution.
I am now a visiting fellow at
the US Holocaust Memorial Museum.
And I will add to the long story
the two speakers spoke about,
which was wrapped altogether
in an opening session
that you got a global picture.
So we are speaking about
global refugees in many senses.
And I would say this
is our message as well.
A lot of the refugees we are
speaking about didn't stay for long
or forever in one of the countries.
It was much more about
more difficult migration.
Not only in Europe, but also
between different continents.
And we were travelling in time.
So you heard about
the interval period.
And I will push you a bit farther
to the time of the Cold War.
And I will stay with Czechoslovakia,
or maybe rather the Czech Republic.
I will explain why.
And I will speak about
Greek Civil War refugees.
It is very strange that, as
Michel already suggested,
it's a difficult time for us to be
observers from another continent,
from oversea, of what is
happening in Europe nowadays.
And how as our country and
our political representatives,
our political elite,
how they are discussing.
And of course our fellow citizens,
how they are discussing the refugee
crisis in the Czech Republic.
What I would like to bring up is
a case which can be an example
of a good practice,
which we all like to see,
especially in today's situation.
And this is based on a case of the
Greek migration at the beginning
of the Cold War and
late-'40's, early-'50's.
Going and bringing us up
to the very recent time.
And I will need to
switch the presentation.
Well, as I already mentioned,
in those days after the second World
War, in the late-'40's, early-'50's,
Greek Civil War refugees were
streaming to the countries
of what became the eastern block.
It's very interesting to
see all the trajectories,
how they came to which country.
Over here from a private
collection you can see a picture not
yet from Czechoslovakia,
but from Bulgaria.
There are all these refugees
gathered for a picture,
for a school picture they were
taking in Bulgaria while they were
about to move to other countries.
And some of them settled
in post-war Czechoslovakia.
It's interesting to see that in
today's terms we are speaking
about temporary asylum
and discussing how long this
temporary asylum is taking.
Experts are telling us there is
not a short-term temporary asylum.
It's much more about refugees
staying and lasting in a country
for about 20 years, until they
may return to their own countries.
And it's not only now.
These Greek Civil War refugees were
staying Czechoslovakia for about 25
or more years, as you will see.
So this has a longer trajectory than
only the time we are speaking about,
which is so vivid for us just today.
Just for clarity, I
would like to say
that during my presentation I will
often speak about Czech Republic
and not Czechoslovakia, even if
historically it was a country
which had an official
name Czechoslovakia.
But since the Greek Civil
War refugees settled only
in the Czech part, in Bohemia
and Moravia, they were coming
to Slovakia only for medical care
and not settling there really.
Excuse me that I do this shortcut
and speak about Czech Republic.
And the other thing is I speak
about Greek Civil War refugees
and maybe sometimes about Greeks.
I am speaking about those
who had Greek citizenship
while leaving their country.
Which doesn't always appeal to
the ethnicity, because in the case
of Czechoslovakia, Czech
Republic, about one-third of them
as you will see were a
Slavic Geek population.
Or Slavomacedonians, as they are
called who had Greek citizenship
but their identity may
have been mixed up.
And of course in the course
of the Cold War they have shifted
their personal identities sometimes
towards the Macedonian
identity in terms
of today's Republic of Macedonia.
So the number of those who were
in Czechoslovakia was quite high.
For my research, which I started
with a group of my students
about six years ago, I used
the Czech National Archive
and other Czech archives
and local archives as well.
And I had the privilege to
record data with my students.
I wouldn't do that on my own.
About 200 hours of interviews of
the first and second generation
of Greek Civil War refugees,
which we recorded with 60 people.
All of the interviews which
were recorded in Czech,
some of them were recorded in Greek.
Unfortunately we didn't find a
platform yet to put them online.
But all of the Czech interviews in
Czech language are accessible online
at the webpage at Memory of Nations.
So those of you who
want to read more
of the personal stories
can try this page as well.
And several segments
are in English as well.
So for those of you
who don't speak Czech,
you may have the first glimpse of
what was happening online as well.
Well, who were the refugees and how
did they come to Czechoslovakia?
How did it all happen?
Just to give you a
historical background,
speaking about Greek Civil
War, it's a long story.
And very often historians
are wrapping it in a way
into three rounds or three circles.
The one, the split within Greek
population was happening already
during the second World War.
And that's sometimes first drawn
around where the leftists
resistance fighters were fighting
against the other fighters,
closer to the republicans,
or maybe best to say
anti-communist views.
Once the second World War in Greece
was over, which was a bit earlier
than we speak about the end of
the second World War in Europe.
And it's already in autumn 1944.
Very soon another round,
a so-called second round
of the Greek Civil War started.
And because it happened in December,
it came up in the history
as the name [inaudible].
This second round, a very violent
one, took only several months.
But we can still speak of a
kind of post-conflict society
and about flourishing democracy
after the second round
of civil war in Greece.
Because very soon after, in
spring 1946, the third round
of Greek Civil War started.
It lasted about three
years and sometimes
in literature you can read only
about the so-called third
round as the civil war.
That was also the timing where
many people were about to escape
from Greece for various reasons.
But mostly because of the fight
which was happening in Greece.
If you imagine the mountainous
territory of norther Greece,
these mountains and villages
were bombed and napalmed
with the help of Greek
western allies.
Because at that point of
course we are already speaking
about a world splitting
in the east and west.
So Greece became a part
of the western world,
whereas those fighters in
the mountains were fighting
for their ideals and for their
political beliefs of communism.
And there were many of them.
But speaking in terms of
the refugees, the peasants,
the Greek peasants in the villages,
they certainly were very afraid
not only of the political violence
which was happening at
that time in Greece.
But I want to remind those
of you who may not know
that there were tens of thousands
of Greeks imprisoned in that period
in Greek prisons and
on solitude islands.
But also several thousand
of them were sentenced
to death and executed.
So this is a very turbulent
atmosphere
in which this all is happening,
just to give you the background.
These people were seeking for
their refuge in the countries
which Greece is neighboring with.
And as you can see, in fact all
of the countries became more
or less part of what would
be called the eastern block.
Of course the differences.
We can't speak of the same political
system in Albania or Yugoslavia.
One different case
was Bulgaria as well.
So these were mostly heading to
the north to those countries.
And you can see that the
division here in 1950,
the number of 76,000 refugees,
which went even higher.
Most historians estimate about
100,000 people who moved only
from Greece and only
within two years.
You see that the number of refugees
in these years is a very big one.
Most of them were heading first
to the neighboring countries,
but they settled or were
moved to other countries.
And as you can see, the number of
Yugoslavia would be the highest one.
It needed to be said that
this number is counting most
of the Slavic-speaking
population in it.
And after the Tito-Stalin
split in '48,
Greeks of Greek ethnicity
were shifted
under different political
circumstances
to other eastern block countries.
Then we have the Soviet Union,
where a lot of political elites
of the Greek communist
party and some
of their family members
were stationed.
As for Czech Republic, which
becomes the third strongest group
in this chart, they were
mostly children coming.
Only within half a year,
4,000 children were
pushed to Czechoslovakia.
As I said, mostly Bohemia
and Moravia.
And elderly people.
Why? Because of the
medical care they needed.
So it was decided that the
social system and medical system
in Czechoslovakia is on the
level that it can absorb
and help this group of population.
So if we speak of the elderly
population, we are discussing now
as being the most endangered
group in this time.
It was a strategically
structured way to put children
and where you could
put elderly people.
What did happen in this time?
Nearly 13,000 refugees by the
time are put in Czechoslovakia.
It's very interesting to
see that they were scattered
in about 24 towns and
villages around Czechoslovakia.
And in a form they were
very close to each other,
at least at the beginning.
The main purpose to put them
in northern Moravia, this part.
And I give you also
the map of Europe just
to give you more general
picture of where
to put Czech Republic on a map.
They were put into those villages
first because they were welcomed
after the explosion
of German population.
But as you could see in
Michel's presentation,
German population was
settled around the borders
and also in some other cities.
But it had to remain
secret, isolated and safe.
So if you want to push refugees in a
part of a country which is isolated,
it's a mountainous area rule.
Which is now without a basic, very
significant group of population.
Which is safe because of
the neighboring Poland,
not like Western Germany or what
became Western Germany, or Austria.
Which can remain secret.
The basic idea was also that
this population should work
in similar conditions as
they worked in Greece,
which was a peasantry
and working as farmers.
But this was very soon
viewed as impossible.
Because at that time the forestry
and the farms, nationalized farms
in Czechoslovakia, which at
that point after the coup de tat
in February '48, became a
part of the eastern block.
Those are very much industrialized
and had a very good industrial
base already from the 19th century.
So very soon the refugees realize
that they can earn a better living
if they go to the industrial
centers, which were in some
of the major towns in this
district which was also in Brno.
So you can see this spot here.
And later on, especially as
they started their education
at universities, et cetera.
Many of them moved to
the capital of Prague.
We can see at this point
that the integration
of the refugees wasn't really
a straightforward process.
And that's what can connect
us with today's situation.
It's not a straightforward process.
It was rather a gradual process
which took several years
and many decisions.
And you have to see the loyalties
of the Greek communist party,
which was exterminated.
Because in Greece it was
already forbidden ever since 1947
and remained forbidden until
the fall of Greek Junta in '74.
So all this period in Greek history
used to be called, and in Greek law
as well, used to be called the
period of the permanent civil war.
So imagine that even in the
fixed Cold War you have a country
in the south of Europe and
you could certainly compare it
with Spain or with Portugal.
You have a country where
you have permanent Civil War
with legal instruments up to '74.
And we have to keep that in mind
when thinking about this division.
So once the refugees
arrive to Czechoslovakia,
I already mentioned
it wasn't an easy way.
It was a very nice experience
lecturing at one of the schools
in the Czech Republic where I was
giving a similar lecture to kids
who were about 10 years old.
And they had the idea and these
kids were surely travelling by train
or by cars or even by airplanes.
No, they went on foot.
So they were crossing the border
on foot towards Albania
and towards Bulgaria.
And from over there, they ended
up going through the Dardanelles
and through Black Sea
to Soviet Union.
Or they made crossing
through the Mediterranean Sea
through to Gibraltar,
around Great Britain
where sometimes the ships
were heavily attacked.
Up to Poland, to Gdansk and then
through Poland to Czechoslovakia.
So you can see the many
trajectories where the blue files,
the yellow files, and that
would be this direction.
Then from Yugoslavia they
were exposed then to Hungary
and later came some of
them to Czechoslovakia.
The other darts we can see here,
that's another difficult story.
Because many of the families ended
up divided in different countries.
And it took one more decade
to reunite the families.
So you have to imagine
children, some children,
living in children's homes
because they were not orphans.
It was not an orphanage.
Without their parents, being
in a different country.
Or maybe being in the very same
country, but they were deprived,
all of them, all who
came to Czechoslovakia,
to stay with their families
until they reached the age of 14
when they started studies
or started to work.
So they were institutionalized,
compulsory in these student homes.
Where they were experiencing
a double education
and in fact a double
indoctrination as well
from the Czech communist party and
an education from Czech teachers.
But also the Greek communist
party and the education
of the very same thing
from the Greek teachers
or Slavic-speaking
teachers from Greece.
So you can see that this
patchwork was working
and that the state agreed
through Soviet Union and Moscow
with Greek communist party and
Czechoslovak communist party
in educating those refugees
in both of the languages.
What happened?
They achieved to make a very
strong feeling of patriotism.
They made them bilingual,
all of them.
And they made them to know
histories of both of the countries,
even if of course shaped in a way
as history was shaped
during the Cold War.
But it seems that this process was
a very successful one because most
of the children, and we don't
have a psychologist telling them,
very good results usually
with children who went
through orphanages
or children's homes.
These children were able to
create their own families,
were very successful
in their new positions.
And most of them, at least the
statistics are saying 80% of them,
finished their university degree,
mostly in technical schools,
medical schools or
pedagogic schools.
Of course the policy
was playing with that.
But I just want to give you a basic
picture of what was happening.
The composition, as I already
mentioned, in Czechoslovakia,
was as you see on the chart.
And I would only like to
highlight some of the usual myths.
And one of the myths is
that it was only communists
who were coming to those countries.
So if you have the number of 13,000
refugees coming to Czechoslovakia,
only 1,000-2,000 of them,
depending on the time period,
were members of the communist party.
And later on of course there was the
growing of the second generation,
which also counts into
these 1,000-2,000 members
of communist party.
The other one is the composition
of Greeks and Slavophones
or Slavomacedonians, but also other
small groups who defined themselves
as Turks or Armans or kind
of Romanian-speaking
population of Greece.
And as I already mentioned,
many of them brought children
and youngsters under the age of 13.
Which of course leads to the fact
that from this group only a
very small number was able
to work immediately
because they were not
at the age of being sent to work.
And Czechoslovakia was
trying to educate them first.
And then we have those
elderly people how are send
to health institutions
and being helped socially.
So the social program
around all this emigration
and about all this emigration was a
very expensive one for 13,000 people
in only about three year's period.
You can see that the ripple creation
took a long time and it can erupt
in all the periods of the Cold War.
So the first group went
back to Greece in fall '54,
which was the time after the death
of Stalin, where the first agreement
between Greece and
Czechoslovakia was signed.
After that, you could
apply only individually.
And if you see that the numbers
are dropping very significantly,
in the '60's when the policy changed
once again and became more relaxed,
bigger number of people is going in.
We have here the Greek Junta
where nearly nobody was going back
because of course people were
scared of persecution back in Greece
and they had reason for that.
After the laws in '74 and later
on in '80-81, with the new rule
of the socialist party of Greece,
[inaudible], many refugees decided
to return back because of
the rules which were issued.
Which outlawed the possibility
to punish them for taking place
in a Greek Civil War resistance.
Just to wrap up, we still do have
about 3,000 Greeks
living in Czechoslovakia.
And what is very significant is the
positive picture they are making
in Czech society.
Greece of course, as with
many other countries,
became the destination
of summer holidays.
But it also is renowned for
its ancient history, et cetera.
But also in a country itself,
it's the former Greek Civil War
refugees running Greek restaurants,
having Greek shops,
who are now the aim
of the visit of the
Czech population.
Greek dancing groups do have
more Czechs that are dancing
in them than Greeks today.
So you can see the intermingling of
these groups was very significant
and didn't really need to
assimilate the population
which is so often discussed.
If a country will accept refugees,
do we assimilate them successfully?
And I do claim the success is to
live with them successfully and not
to assimilate them, because
we all can gain from that.
It doesn't matter if they have
a Czech national identity,
as you can see, or a Stephanos who
is claiming that he was born Greek
and he will die Greek even if
he never, ever travelled again
to Greece after he
came to Czechoslovakia.
And it's not a big distance.
It's two hours by plane and
it's not that expensive either.
But he doesn't want to
destroy his picture of Greece.
He wants to remain
Greek in Czechoslovakia.
And this is in my opinion
the message we have to spread
to today's society as well.
If you have the chance to read in
Czech or Greek, you will get a story
of all of those, their
identities, their political views,
their life in Czechoslovakia,
either in Greek or in Czech.
Unfortunately not in English, but I
hope to sum it up one day at least
in an article that you can
have for all of you on that.
Thank you very much
for your attention.
[ Applause ]
>> Gail Shirazi: We have
time for a few questions
if anybody has a question
for any one of the speakers.
Yes?
>> I actually have an ethical
question to Dr. Frankl.
But I also have a question
for all three of you.
First of all, when you were
talking about the 1938 exile,
how did that timing
with the Anschluss
with other things motivate people
to run into that in that time frame?
>> Gail Shirazi: Do you want
to come up to the microphone?
And we'll have to repeat part
of the question for the webcast.
So if you come up and
repeat part of the question.
>> Michel Frankl: Okay.
Thank you for the question
about the -- this one, here?
Basically about the series
of events and the timeframe
and how this motivated
people to leave.
I must say I've skipped
most of the fact simply
because of the time
that I had for the talk.
Let me just go one step back.
And it is a pre-story from 1933.
In terms of closed borders and
refugees, it also has a history
at the turn of 1937 and
1938 when the Czechoslovaks
for the first time sealed the
borders for Romanian refugees.
It was a short period when Romani
was governed by pro-fascist
and very anti-Semitic government.
And Czechoslovak officials fear
that the country will
be flooded very soon
with Jewish and communist refugees.
It was the same category
for them anyway.
And it is interesting
from the point of view
that there were actually no
refugees coming right now.
It was the image of the
imminent refugee danger,
rather than a reality
to which they reacted.
Some weeks later, just a couple
of weeks later, March 1938,
when the Nazi Anschluss of
Austria, this is the moment
when real refugees are coming.
And they have to come very quickly.
Since a lot of people were
hoping that all those --
Austria 1930's was a
large anti-Semitic state
and quite an oppressive state.
It was not that dangerous
to live there.
They would think [inaudible].
But also in the crisis which ended
up by the Nazi takeover of Austria.
A lot of these people
were opponents of Nazism.
They were hoping to stay until the
referendum, which was scheduled
to be just some days afterward.
So people like Burman and others
were staying till the last moment.
And then they were fleeing.
One thing that I haven't mentioned
and should have mentioned is
that a lot of them are not
fleeing by their own decision,
but they were simply expelled.
Especially if these refugees did
not have Austrian citizenship.
This is the case of a lot of people
who fled in the first World War.
There were a lot of Jews who
fled in the first World War
from Galicia especially
and stayed in Vienna.
But they were never naturalized.
So there is yet another group of
Jews who were expelled from Austria
or fleeing, and those are
Jews with Polish citizenship
who are being basically channeled
through Czechoslovakia to Poland.
And in Poland this leads to
a revision of citizenship.
This revision of citizenship
will mean
that Polish Jews living abroad
won't keep their Polish passports,
or these Polish passports wouldn't
allow them to come back to Poland.
This led to the expulsion of
Polish Jews from Germany at the end
of October 1978, something
I haven't mentioned at all.
And this is an event
which is also connected
to this history of
the Kristallnacht.
Perhaps a couple of words
about Czechoslovakia.
As you have seen I have
largely skipped facts
about the post-Munich refugees
simply because it's a huge topic.
But we need to take into
account that this is one
of the most extensive bases of
refugees in Czechoslovakian history.
Basically comparable only
to the first World War.
It can be somewhere around say the
end of 1938 some 200,000 who escape
after the Munich Agreement
or before,
during and after the
Munich Agreement.
And after the Kristallnacht
from the border areas.
Most of them are Czechs.
But among them there are probably
some 20,000 Jews and 20,000 Germans.
So I don't know if that answered.
And these events are connected.
There's a chain of events.
>> The second question is a
personal question for all three.
Do you all three have family
histories that went through this,
that motivated you
to study this area?
>> Gail Shirazi: Repeat
the question please.
>> Michel Frankl: The
question is whether the three
of us speakers have personal
histories, family histories
that would motivate us
to deal with this topic.
But in my case, my family histories
are connected to the Holocaust
and partially also these
are refugee histories.
But I'm not sure that
this motivated me
to specifically look
into this topic.
I started to deal with the
history of anti-Semitism
when I was searching for
a topic for my BA thesis.
And I discovered that the
topic, which I'm not going
to describe here, is
largely undescribed
and unanalyzed in the
historiography.
>> Gail Shirazi: Katerina?
>> Katerina Kralova: Well
you will be surprised.
I have no other connection
than academic connection.
And connection with my older years,
which I spent in Greece
traveling for my research.
I have no Greek family background.
My research started
mainly with my Ph. D thesis
on Greek-German relations
and a shade of Nazi past.
And I was always asked if
I have a Greek background.
And I was always pushed
that I should do something
about Greeks living
in Czechoslovakia.
And it was a big task and it was
a marvelous task and I did it.
But there is no personal connection.
In fact, my grandmother
too, who is still among us,
which I am very happy for,
she is a Holocaust survivor.
So again, there are tragic
experiences in the family,
but none of them is
related to Greece.
But it's an amazing
topic to be researched.
>> Amy Kaslow: Mine
will be very brief.
The short answer is no.
But a fierce determination to
learn and once you learn the plight
of one people, it's irresistible
to learn that of others.
>> Gail Shirazi: We have
time for one more question.
>> My question is for
you, Dr. Kralova.
I was happy to hear how
integrated the refugees were
who came in the '40's.
And I know refugees that come to the
United States, they have the ability
to become American citizens
without too much trouble.
At the end you said
most of the dancers,
the Greek dancers, are Czech.
So why is it that after 70
years they're still identified
as Czech if they never left?
Are they Greek citizens?
Or how does that work exactly?
Or do they still live in Greek
enclaves in the Czech Republic?
>> Katerina Kralova: Well
the question would be
about citizenship reflecting
the Czech and Greek identities
in Czech Republic nowadays.
And how these people
achieve their acculturation
and adaptation in a society.
Of course I had 20 minutes and
I had to skip so many things.
So of course it was
not always ideal.
And of course we have
mentionings, especially in archives.
Never, ever did it come
up in oral testimony,
which was very interesting.
If we asked directly we
were a mixed up group.
So it was not only Czechs who
were interviewing the Greek Civil
War refugees.
So we could say, you know,
if you speak with a Greek Civil War
refugee maybe you will be more open
about that experience you
experienced in the country.
It never really came
up in the interviews
which for me was very
interesting and I didn't expect it.
However, in the archives,
and we have to admit
that recording interviews
five years ago, six years ago,
we couldn't reach to all the first
generation of people who were
at adult age or elderly when
they came to Czechoslovakia.
Maybe we would get another picture
if we had done the
recording 20 years earlier.
In archives we can trace.
There was a certain xenophobia in
the beginning, but it was overcome.
Now to the question of citizenship,
that's a very interesting question.
Czechoslovakia in the time
of the Cold War didn't
allow anybody in Greece.
It was very complicated to the
law against those who were put
in the group of communists,
and who therefore could lose
or would lose their citizenship
once they leave the country
because of political reasons.
There were other groups.
It was very interesting what
defines you as being Greek,
which was the Greek
orthodoxy and the language.
Greece until nowadays doesn't
acknowledge national minorities,
only religious minorities,
the traditional one.
So if you were Jewish,
if you were Muslim,
then you were a religious minority
but you won't be a Jew
as a national minority.
You won't be a Turk as a
national minority and so on.
So this is one of the
frames back to Greece.
And in Czechoslovakia you were not
allowed to have double citizenship.
So in this situation people
had to make the decision,
"Do I take a Czech citizenship
and then will be more vulnerable
to losing my Greek citizenship
and maybe never have the
opportunity to go back?"
Because Greeks see me
as a Czech citizen.
Therefore I won't be able to
apply for my Greek properties
and everything I lost
because of the war.
So this was a very difficult thing.
In fact, until the end of the
Cold War, only several thousand
in all the years applied for
-- several hundred, sorry,
applied for Czech citizenship.
So virtually nobody of this group
of the primary 12,000-plus people.
But the second generation more
and more did not have
a Czech citizenship.
It was complicated, especially once
they were able to cross the border
and so forth because they didn't
have proper documentation.
So travelling for the first time
back to Greece they had a kind
of paper issued that they
can cross the borders,
but nobody really knew what
does it mean, et cetera.
So this was a complicated
situation of citizenship.
On the other hand, we have to move
ourselves back to the Cold War.
Crossing borders was not
an easy task back then.
So you mainly and for most remained
in the country where you lived in.
So you didn't really
have the feeling, "Oh,
I can't go to neighboring Austria
because I don't have passport."
You couldn't go anyway.
So this is something we have to
understand and to base limits
of globalized society where the
passport is a very important thing.
Back then it was approached
in a different way.
So this is an important thing.
Speaking about Greek
dancers, it's interesting
because the Greek dancers
are mostly being the first --
not anymore -- they vary.
Second and third generation,
many of them.
But of course open
to the whole society.
Locally there is a lot of
dancing being done on a more
or less professional level.
So they are still Greek dancers,
second and third generation,
who are even doing all
their costumes by their hand
as they did back in
the Cold War et cetera.
And who are travelling
to Greek dance festivals.
Then the group is mostly Greek.
But doing it as a hobby in your
leisure time, the group changes.
And of course because as I said,
remember in all the republic,
and we have 13 communities now.
So it's scattered in a little
country of 11 million people.
You have 3,000 of Greeks who
are still that distinguished,
which is very interesting.
And they attach to those
activities the majority population.
[ Applause ]
>> Gail Shirazi: Thank
you all for coming.
If you want to come up informally
in a little bit and speak with them
and answer the rest
of your questions.
I'm sorry, we've run out of time.
But thank you very much.
And I'm going to thank the
speakers and the Embassy very much.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.